he leads Florida in terms of ice time Gustaf
forsling now tan of and back of the go denied
Reinhardt forsling hammers one wide and the
kin all the way back Florida has the fourth
best defensive record in the NHL poring
eblad to the outside Reinhardt stopped a
couple of times by dord a little hack
and whack time and it's fed out 52 in
deep sea blue out to the slot good stick
by the Panthers that was ver hagy and out
they are this is eblad right in for a shot
stopped by dord spectacular save by Joey
dord well joy has to be ready for this one
don't want third shot of the game to be a
breakaway eblad coming in gets that right
pad off 16 goals with Colorado a season ago
good years with Pittsburgh too now it comes
back for Brandon Montour shot swallowed up
by dor no rebound mikola for his partner Brandon
Montour from UMass Amherst back in the day broken
up kin Shaw and the off Wi a shot swallowed up
easily by Sergey bosski he lay it along in the
skapes of baners who does a good job to play it
Florida though they'll take over mikola and now
linan through Center this way it's forsing a
shot stopped covered by dord survives it gets
it out flung in by Adam Larson abosi directing
traffic now manour right on the money Matthew
kachuck with a shop blocker save to court it goes
High s Bennett stolen by Dunn Dunn under pressure
from Bennett tugged a bit they play on out of the
scrum it's loose cousins grinding kachuck to the
point now to the point Mika tipped turned out
by dord the tip from Nick cousins binus lomberg
and now stenland interrupted by Belmar Pierre
Edward bmar storming in the zone out of the
corner pulled back for Adam Larson Larson with
a shot easy stop seen all the way by bosski the
guy they call Bob that's ingenus it comes out
to center now through the middle of the ice
here comes Bennett Bennett now with shot P down
and covered lomberg now will take it back under
pressure from Tai Kier Adam Larson with a shot
stopped the rebound stopped bosski has lost his
stick Jamie alexc was off Deon
Shore he had a good opportunity
in Period one Belmar lays it back for
borgan stretching out the ice Yamamoto
he's in he scores Kyler Yamamoto to
the roof and the Kraken break the
ice well that one's got to feel real good for
Kyler Yamamoto great feed by borgan sets him
off to the the race is L backand forehand shovels
it quickly right up over a beautiful finish goal
SC type goal right underneath the bar now bork
strand with a shot stopped by brosi and he got the
rebound to in knocking on the door Sasha barov now
for haggy here's kachak an extended period of time
here no possession for haggy off a stick out in
front emman Larson hunts it down now Ekman Larson
holding on to it no shooting Lane kachuck with a
shot bought off by dord blown dead taken down by
alexc Sam Bennett curls away from Adam Larson
beautiful play by the big cat mccan alexc here
they come short-handed for now Alexia in the zone
a backhander denied oh a great stick by forsling
on gourd theyve been excellent out to center lenan
stenland with a shot stopped by dord he's down it
caught him high 38 seconds left on the Kraken kill
gourd spots Brandon tanet turbo through Center
one-on-one montour's back he'll swing a shot
turned aside by bosski to the point per two power
plays they got three wow forsling through traffic
caught by dord he's got it slingshot it back for
Alex wiberg he mccan Everly Evans and gour on
the ice mccan draws it to Evans mccan right place
right time what a stop Rosy off G two shots for
the Kraken in the power play lomberg is out of the
box and it comes back deeper in the zone
mour waiting in the corner Yamamoto done
Belmar kicked out the rebound plung wide
amoto looking for his second goal of the
game and it comes out to Center Ice Adam
Larson Here Comes Ellie tolven in it's
offside oh what a chance out in front nice little
play here from Yamamoto to find Vince dun Montour
through Center Reinhardt at the line stood up
by Larson Montour goes deep on wber bhi here's
Mika at the point a hand off stenland Montour
off the side of the goal maybe the outside of
the goal post for heggy in front off the court
this is the best game in a long while for the
fourth line they've been able to get out in
rotation get quality minutes and factor in
Yamamoto Evans Evans now circles the track
out in front they score that's hockey baby
Pier Edward belmer first NHL Point rker Evans two
nothing thing Seattle all starting at the face off
you win a draw you go deep down the wall great
play Here by rker Evans to throw that back to
the front of the net and the man who won The Face
Off Belmar all alone out in front great feed from
rker Evans for his first National Hockey League
point and third goal of the Season can't be easy
when your head's probably just ringing a little
bit after the first one right off the The Mask
and Alexia all the way around cier Morgan wenberg
he's in he scores hey hey what
do you say Alex wiberg 3 nothing
Kraken great Puck movement through the
neutral zone D's going to make their way
borgan jumping up sends M all the way around
again linan stolen by Matty bers great pass
toin in the loone stopped bosski good work
through the neutral zone here Matty with a
nice sauce pass to hit toinen with speed
quick little play trying to hit the five
hole on bosi and just a little bit too elevated
there there ends up hitting him Reinhardt ver
hay in front off bodies off gourd captured by
Vince dun angled out to Center emman Larson a
foot race with tolven and who hacks it in Elly
tolin wills at home empty net goal great job
by dun getting it out into the neutral zone
not sending it for an ice this time allowing
tolin to skate into that Puck and just ends
up outworking eing Larsson here for the puck
it's a 50/50 battle toen gets his stick down to
the inside and just swipes that one towards the
net just a good effort play
right there 6 seconds on the
clock that's Kraken hockey baby that's
the first career shut out for Joey DOR